wenn ich jetzt die WM nicht schauen will
und mich langsam mal dran gewöhnen muss
nicht mehr Fußball zu gucken wie kann
ich dann da langsam anfangen vielleicht
dass ich erstmal nur Spiele von Gladbach
boykottiere
also aus einer Sucht Ritt mir raus indem
er seine Rituale ändert oft auch das
Umfeld ändert man kann auch in so einer
fußballkneipe dann sich treffen wenn
wenn die Leinwand dunkel ist und sicher
statt Fußball z.B die asiatischen
Winterspielen Saudi Arabien gucken und
dann müssen wir das nicht Verlagerung
kommen denn wenn die wenn das aber die
zeigt mir nicht die Frage
also nicht dass dann die Sucht in der
Kneipe weitergeht also das ist da müsste
man genau hingucken was ist es
eigentlich die was macht die Bindung aus
ich würde auch sagen wahrscheinlich in
seiner Kneipe dann reicht es nicht wenn
die Leinwand dunkel bleibt und dann muss
man spazieren machen bisschen Sport
machen man muss sich anders erleben und
spüren ja ich glaube so wird es nicht
wie könnte ich denn jetzt praktisch ich
sitze zu Hause wie kann ich mich davon
abhalten den Fernseher einzuschalten
kauf dir einen Hund
haben sie einen Hund zwei warum
boykottieren sie denn da nicht die WM
zwischendurch gehe ich mal Gassi
innerhalb der Pause wenn der Kracher
Katar gegen Ecuador läuft ja die können
sehr interessant sein die Frage ist mit
welchen Blick man dahin guckt ja gut als
FC-Trainer gucken sie dann natürlich auf
potenzielle Spieler ne so siehts aus
spielen die halt wo wir hierher holen
und dann machen wir Stars also wichtig
ist aus der Fixierung rauszukommen wenn
sie wenn sie nur ähm warten drauf wann
beginnt der wann beginnt die Übertragung
das dann klappt es nicht also man muss
wirklich aus der Bindung raus und und
überlegen was würde mir Spaß machen
und wenn da nichts ist dann würde ich
mir mal Gedanken machen was ich für
Leben für
das geht jetzt hier eine ganz falsche
Richtung finde ich das Gespräch
begleiten Sie mich auch
Empathie würde ich sagen empathie ist da
Mitgefühl er empathie ist nicht mein
Ding mein Ansichtspunkt ist aber so dass
ich sage es ist jetzt aber auch passiert
es ist passiert es ist die Vergabe wir
konnten uns lange damit
auseinandersetzen jetzt kommt die WM und
deswegen werde ich sie auch schauen kann
man uns das jetzt noch abtrainieren
diese fußballsucht oder ist es dafür
schon zu spät
also ich halte die fußballsucht für bei
der Nationalmannschaft sowieso eher für
eine weiche Droge also ähm Hardcore ist
der eher der FC Köln das ist Eintracht
Frankfurt aber die Nationalmannschaft
ist für mich immer ähm was man auf
professionellen Kunden guckt weil man
sehen will wer entwickelt sich der
fußballweit weiter kann man denn loben
dass ich Herr Baumgart zumindest schon
mal eine Mannschaft mit Spielern
ausgesucht hat die rein sportlich die WM
boykottieren
sie können auch gerne antworten
[Gelächter]
Sie sich denn vorstellen jemals Katar zu
trainieren
im Fußball sage ich zu nichts nein kann
man also aus moralischer Sicht
katar-trainer sein trotz der Bedingung
vor Ort
ja genau das ist es ja dann vor Ort sein
dann gucken dann schauen und sich ein
eigenes Bild machen und vielleicht auch
dann vielleicht gegen das ein oder
andere nicht demonstrieren und auch
nicht gegen sondern
vermeiden nein aber ich glaube nur so
kannst du wirklich sehen was da abgeht
ja ich habe noch eine moralische Frage
ist es okay wenn ich die Spiele schaue
dabei aber keine Freude empfinde
aus der Sicht der Drogenberatung ist es
nicht keine Moral wichtig da darf man da
darf man das machen und soll das machen
was man was einem weiterhilft und und
wenn sie unruhig sind weil sie spielen
nicht schauen können dann gehen Sie
spazieren wenn sie nicht schlafen können
sie müssen dadurch
wie sehen Sie das also die Frage die Du
gestellt hast kann ich dir beantworten
du hast ja schon viele Spiele gesehen wo
du dich nicht freust also deswegen wird
sich da ja nicht wenig verändern also
dadurch wirst du deine Sucht nicht
verändern wie finden sie das das Public
Viewing größtenteils abgesagt wird das
finde ich eine in Ordnung das ist eine
klare Meinung und das finde ich kann man
auch so dann vertreten das bedeutet aber
nicht was der Einzelne macht und das
halte ich auch für okay und wir können
es auch nicht dann öffentlich feiern
wenn wir ganz klar mit dem Finger darauf
zeigen und dann bin ich auch komplett
dabei das eine hat mit dem anderen nicht
zu tun und es gibt ja dann auch den
öffentlichen Raum es gibt den privaten
Raum das heißt sie gucken die wir immer
machen den Vorhang zu ich mache es im
Dunkeln ja was ist denn das größte
moralische Dilemma diesen Winter die WM
oder das Gas aus Katar
[Gelächter]
ja also wenn ich die WM gucke und dabei
friere wäre das okay
als
drogenberaterischer Sicht habe ich gerne
moralischen kann ich keine moralischen
Fragen beantworten also das ich bin froh
wenn wenn wir Gas haben und nicht
frieren müssen aber
ich weiß mir natürlich auch in den Arsch
wenn es aus Katar sein musste und ja
ich beiß mir nicht in den Arsch ich will
als einfach nur warm haben gut dann zum
Abschluss die Frage sie kennen mich
jetzt ein bisschen glauben Sie ich
schaffe es die WM zu boykottieren
ja und damit zurück ins Studio
hallo Youtube unten könnt ihr den Kanal
abonnieren er deutet nach unten in die
Infobox neben mir gibt es weitere
interessante Videos Verlinkungen Komma
vielen Dank
[Musik]